The 12th most common misconception
regarding Islam amongst the non-Muslim
is the non-Muslims say you Muslims you
know today science tells us what you eat
has an effect on your behavior. You eat
animals and you behave like animals
violent.
I say I agree with you. I know there is
a research what you eat has an effect on
your behavior. There is a research.
That's the reason we Muslims
we never eat the carnivorous ferocious
animal like lion, tiger, leopard because
we don't want to be ferocious and
violent. We eat the herbivorous animal
like cow, goat, sheep which are
peaceloving animals because we Muslim
want to be peaceful.
So if you agree with the research what
you eat has effect on a behavior we eat
only peaceful animals the herbivorous
animal like cow, goat, sheep because we
are peaceloving we are not allowed to
eat the ferocious animal like lion,
tiger, leopard, wolf
because we don't want to be ferocious
and Allah says in the Quran in surah
araf chapter number 7 verse number 157
they followed the unlettered prophet
And he commands them what is just and
pure
and prohibits them that which is evil
and impure. He allows them to have that
which is good and pure and just and
prevents them from having that which is
evil, bad and impure. And there are
various hadith which tell us
what type of animals we cannot have. We
already
one of them mentioned in the Quran
clearly
in surah maza ch 5 verse number three is
spoke which we shall discuss later on.
But there are various hadith of the
prophet which tells us what kind of
animals we cannot eat. Our beloved
prophet said it's mentioned in Sai Bkari
volume number five had number 4994 as
well as Maja had number 3248 3249 and
and there are many other say hadith
which tell what the prophet has
prohibited. The prophet said you cannot
eat these categories of animal. The
carnivorous animals
belonging to the cat family like the
lion,
the tiger, the leopard, the cheetah, the
cat, the dog, the wolf,
all these carnivorous, any carnivorous
animal you cannot eat. Any carnivorous
animal cannot eat. Number two, you
cannot have rodents like the mice, the
rat, rabbits with claws.
You cannot
have alligators like snake,
alligators, etc. And you cannot have
birds of prey which have claws and
talons like owl, crow, vulture, eagle.
All these types of animals are
prohibited for you to have.